Linda Hersman what gave you the idea to
write about Sandra Day O'Connor and Ruth
Bader Ginsburg so I write books about
social movements so I was interested in
how women had achieved formal legal
equality which is a happy story it has a
happy ending
so I started thinking about Ruth Bader
Ginsburg you can't it's like you can't
think about that subject without
thinking about Ruth Bader Ginsburg from
her time on the court but more
importantly from when she was at the
ACLU in the 70s and til she went on the
bench so was an obvious subject but if
you think about it she was second on the
Supreme Court Sandra Day O'Connor came
to the Supreme Court first and she was
the symbol and the icon that women could
rise to the highest jobs in the land so
she did a lot for women's equality as
well as Ginsburg so I thought well do
they know each other right do they go
out for lunch and shopping for shoes
right no the answer is no they know each
other but they do not go shoe shopping
together but they made an alliance and
affectionate alliance which made both of
them more powerful than they would have
been alone so not only was it the story
of what they did in decisions helping
women to be equal but the way that they
helped each other to succeed Sandra Day
O'Connor said when Reagan appointed her
it's okay to be the first but I do not
want to be the last and she paved the
way for Ruth Bader Ginsburg to come on
the court and be welcome without
question because she O'Connor was so
successful and when Ginsberg came
O'Connor was so happy because Ginsburg
is so unbelievably excellent at her job
that she was going to be another
successful woman just like O'Connor had
hoped so I wrote about what they did for
women and how they acted together to
jewel for women which is a model for
women in the future to know that you can
be allies without being BFFs and how you
can action together make the world
better than either one of you could
alone and then when I started looking at
the cases it turns out the cases are
very interesting so I wanted to make it
for lay readers to be able to understand
how they did a case by case it's going
to be a big term in the Supreme Court
this coming June by June we're gonna
have a lot of Supreme Court decisions
about women and I wanted my readers
whether they were lawyers or not to
understand
how these women did it how they change
the law for women so I did all of those
things in this book did you find a
significant case where they each wrote
opposing opinions it was a case where
they disagreed there were a couple but
but there's one where the struck down as
unconstitutional a portion of the
Violence Against Women Act the Supreme
Court said that that Violence Against
Women Act was beyond the authority of
the federal government to write that law
and O'Connor is always very conservative
remember she's a Republican and she
comes from a Republican president she
was always very conservative on what was
for the states and what was for the
federal government so she said it was
unconstitutional and Ruth Bader Ginsberg
of course said that the Violence Against
Women Act met the constitutional
standards that was one of the very very
very few cases about women where they
disagree they agreed there must have
been 25 ought to gether and they agreed
on all but two of them so even though
one was a Republican and one was a
Democrat and one was a blonde and one
was a brunette a very important
distinction and one came from Arizona
and one from Brooklyn on women's issues
22 cases out of 24 same side so it's a
pretty good record and a pretty good
reflection of what they knew was
important for them to do
did they did they grant interviews to
you I met with each of them gives work
said she would cooperate if O'Conner
would cooperate and O'Connor said there
wasn't enough material here for a book
Oh almost 400 and what's wonderful about
it is that it tells the story of how
Ginsburg started at the ACLU and then
she goes to the DC Circuit and O'Connor
like picks up the baton and carries
women's equality forward while she's on
the Supreme Court of the United States
and then at the critical moment in 1993
gives four commas on to the Supreme
Court and now since 2005 Ginsburg has
been carrying on a torch so I was able
to go back and forth between them
without much difficulty as a writer
because the important the spotlight went
from one to the other in a very orderly
way now we have Sotomayor and Kagan who
are caring look forward in a different
and more powerful way built on the
shoulders of the women who preceded them
so it was easy to write it was an easy
book